qui est pour qui est contre la science
est levée
la séance est levée
nous voici en Mayenne à 300 km de la
capitale
bonjour je suis Guillaume Garreau je
suis député de la première
circonscription de la Mayenne bonjour je
suis Yannick Favennec député de la
troisième circonscription de la Mayenne
et ensemble nous nous battons contre les
déserts médicaux alors à tout de suite à
tout de suite
et socialiste l'autre de la majorité
présidentielle et ensemble ils ont créé
un groupe transpartisan à l'Assemblée
nationale
lors département est considéré comme le
troisième désert médical de France pour
un habitant sur 10 trouvèrent un médecin
relève du parcours du combattant
la tournée des députés commence dans ce
village de 1900 habitants
on y est très bien
une école et même une maison de santé 2
ans de travaux 500000 euros investis qui
n'ont pourtant pas suffi à garder le
médecin local
il a exercé pendant 6 mois 7 mois
peut-être un petit peu plus et puis
après il a décidé de nous quitter sans
préavis
combien de temps
et c'est la maison santé que vous aviez
construite selon ses
demandes autour de moi
direction le centre de santé d'autres
professionnels se sont installés ici
infirmière ou encore kiné mais rien n'y
fait aucun médecin à l'horizon
[Musique]
face à face
de désert médicaux et ça fait 20 ans
qu'on fait de l'incitation avec l'argent
public avec beaucoup d'argent public et
c'est la raison pour laquelle il y a un
moment où on se dit peut-être qu'il faut
changer de braquet faire de l'incitation
oui mais ajouter de la régulation une
répartition sur l'ensemble du territoire
des médecins
[Musique]
si l'incitation me suffit pas les
députés ont un remède serrez la vis et
obligé à l'installation des médecins
dans les zones sous dotées donc là on va
voir la formation un peu à l'image des
pharmaciens qui ne peuvent s'installer
qu'avec une autorisation
vous pensez quoi de la régulation que
nous vous êtes ce que vous aimez déjà la
régulation
je pense que c'est très compliqué quoi
inciter un
médecin s'installer dans une zone où il
a pas envie de vivre
ça me paraît très compliqué et pourquoi
ça le serait moins pour les pharmacies
là
le pharmacien n'est pas obligé de
s'installer dans une région
on n'est pas en train d'en prendre un là
pour dire tu iras là mais allez comme le
disait Yannick là où on a besoin de VOUS
très forte mais avec une régulation
puisqu'il faut des règles voilà la règle
l'obligation dans ce que j'avais entendu
mais il peut y avoir une obligation qui
qui soit transitoire mais ensuite chacun
voilà sur une période donnée mais après
les gens les médecins
pourraient aller là où ils veulent
régulation incitation forte obligation
transitoire autant de mots pour désigner
la fin de la libre installation des
médecins en place depuis 1921 les
députés marchent sur des œufs si on veut
être un député efficace à Paris il faut
d'abord être un député ancré voilà si on
n'est pas sur le terrain ça marchera pas
à Laval dans ce centre médical 13
médecins retraités ont renfilé la blouse
pour prêter main-forte ils viennent
aussi former les jeunes internes
bonjour
je m'appelle
ministre etc tu peux lui dire monsieur
le ministre
là vous êtes en quelle année là
[Musique]
et la suite ce sera quoi pour vous
projet professionnel c'est plutôt être
dans du semi rural au début quand j'ai
commencé la médecine je partais vraiment
sur du montage et en fait je me suis
rendu compte que ça répondait pas à mes
besoins mais enfin ma façon et elle a
dit que j'ai de la médecine parce que le
problème du rural c'est qu'on est quand
même assez isolé d'avoir des céto jeunes
internes comme Alice que le député veut
demander des efforts une année
supplémentaire d'internat sur le terrain
dans les zones sans médecin
[Musique]
je pense que déjà on se mobilise tous
nous les retraités
la situation actuelle si on ne fait rien
va prendre des tours terribles
dramatique parce que la pyramide des
âges fait que on va de vert le plus
difficile le plus dur est à venir donc
nécessairement il faut qu'on trouve des
solutions je dis pas que c'est simple je
dis pas qu'il y a qu'une solution mais
je dis que nécessairement on va devoir
se mettre autour d'une table et discuter
de la façon dont aujourd'hui on rend la
médecine en France merci beaucoup
docteur à bientôt avec plaisir
m'apporter aussi du jour ouverte pour
discuter
Guillaume Garraud a conscience de la
gravité de la situation
députée depuis 15 ans chaque semaine les
lus socialistes reçoit les témoignages
mes parents ont essayé depuis plusieurs
mois de trouver un nouveau médecin sur
Évron et sur monsure mais cela s'avère
impossible monde dentiste est parti en
retraite j'essaie désespérément de
trouver un praticien qui accepte de me
donner un rendez-vous au moins 15 appels
infructueux depuis des mois je nécessite
chercher médecin traitant impossible
ophtalmologiste impossible
chirurgien-dentiste pour crise aiguë
dentaire et soins impératifs impossible
j'ai obtenu une consultation à Gorron
c'est-à-dire à 69 km de chez moi ça
c'est notre quotidien donc ça fait moi
des années que je me bats l'Assemblée
pour que on change les règles de
l'exercice et de l'installation de nos
médecins en France
des lettres mais également des images
en septembre dernier dans le département
de Guillaume Garraud des centaines de
personnes patientes pour s'inscrire
auprès d'un nouveau médecin personne ne
prend mon chien est soigné
[Musique]
au total 160 médecins généralistes sont
installés en Mayenne il en faudrait le
double
dans le cabinet médical de
Martigné-sur-Mayenne
Océane 23 ans et 100 médecins depuis
janvier elle a fait plus d'une
demi-heure de route dans l'espoir de
rentrer dans la patientèle de ce docteur
tout juste installé j'ai appelé beaucoup
de médecins autour de chez moi et
personne voulait me prendre donc ça a
été très très compliqué je me suis même
déplacée à la CPAM pour essayer d'avoir
une liste et personne personne voulait
prendre et qu'est-ce que vous attendez
du docteur qu'elle devient de votre
médecin traitant oui oui
avec moi
vous êtes la fille de même Denis qui m'a
parlé de vous et vous n'avez pas de
médecin traitant c'est ça vous pouvez
pas du tout dans votre secteur pas du
tout très compliqué
dans votre partie de débarquement de
département je vous accepterai sur ma
passion tel pour faire un suivi de
famille merci à vous en tout cas
Océane est soulagée elle entre dans la
passion telle déjà chargée du docteur
en seulement quatre mois docteur Groff
est devenu le médecin traitant de 610
patients
je réponds à une demande cliente là sur
le territoire de Martigny et je reprends
des patients qui n'avaient plus de
médecins depuis 2 ans de tous âges de
l'enfant jusqu'au patient de plus de 90
ans qui retrouve un médecin après deux
ans sans suivi et la dame que j'ai vu ce
matin qui avait plus de 80 ans en
arrivant c'est assise et m'a dit docteur
si vous saviez comme ça fait du bien de
se lever le matin et de savoir qu'on va
voir son médecin traitant
il y a deux ans les deux médecins de
Martigny prennent leur retraite et
personne ne sait bousculé au portillon
pour les remplacer
la commune a alors trouvé une solution
salariée le médecin
n'aboutissement pour moi d'être ici
et j'étais au 42e régiment de
transmission à Laval et puis onzième
régiment d'artillerie de mars
aux urgences de l'hôpital de Mayenne
jusqu'à encore maintenant le choix de la
médecine générale salarié c'était votre
choix vous n'avez jamais envisagé d'être
de vous installer comme libéral non
parce que c'est un exercice que je
maîtrise pas le comptabilité générale et
j'ai toujours été dans dans
l'institution publique en étant dans la
défense puis dans le dans l'Hospitalier
pour moi c'est le libéral ne correspond
pas
le territorial maintenant c'est c'est
idéal c'est idéal mais ma situation est
très particulière et peut pas être
calqué l'ensemble des futurs médecins
généralistes qui vont arriver qui sont
en formation qui sont déjà installés
mais ça fait partie des solutions on a
procédé aussi à beaucoup d'auditions
dans notre groupe de travail
transpartisans qu'on a qu'on a créé et
on voit bien l'exercice groupé en réseau
salariés pour certains c'est c'est ça
qui est attendu aujourd'hui par les
professionnels et les plus jeunes en
particulier bon ben écoutez très bien on
va vous laisser vous laisser travailler
parce que le plus important pour vous là
Guillaume Garraud Yannick Favennec
continue de sillonner leur
circonscription merci beaucoup bonne
continuation merci
grâce au travail de leur groupe
transpartisans qui réunit 50 députés de
la France insoumise aux républicains ils
espèrent trouver un écho favorable à
leur futur proposition de loi
[Musique]